les individus nord s'ils n'ont pas à un
au dénominateur commun qui s'appelle la
nation qui produit des règles communes
mais les règles c'est passé comme dit
permanence et les valeurs la république
les règles républicaines c'est un tuyau
on a besoin d'un contenu qui nous
rassemble qui nous réunit ce contenu qui
doit transcender nos origines
notre condition sociale notre éventuel
religion etc notre sexe c'est un
substrat qui effet de mode de vie qui
est fait de partager des grandes oeuvres
de l'esprit c'est pour ça qu'avec
christophe tardieu on a écrit ce livre
s'appelle la culture nous sort qui est
fait de deux de la raison critique de
mode de pensée comme un c'est pas
forcément une machine à broyer là aussi
il faut trouver un bon équilibre mais
regard raisonner par l'absurde et je
refile ma boucle quand vous me dites ça
s'opposent à des groupes etc mais ces
groupes-là eux ni l'individu moi je
pense qu aujourd hui la nation et la
république est venu protectrice de
l'individu que l'universalisme
républicain et protecteur d'individus
comme quand vous êtes dans dans un
univers qui ne voit qu'un élément de
votre identité si vous n'êtes que blanc
de plus de 50 ans où vous n'êtes que
maghrébins où vous n'êtes que riche où
vous n'êtes que femme ça devient un
essentialisme et que cet essentialisme
là la meilleure façon de le contrer
c'est l'esprit républicain c'est là les
valeurs qui sont anciennes de la france
sont pas que républicaine c'est c'est
c'est un substrat qui vient de là la de
la logique grec du droit romain de la
grande culture judéo chrétienne de
l'esprit des lumières le il ya une une
permanence de la france et il ya cet
universalisme républicain qui est pas
née pour rien en france et aux états
unis d'ailleurs mais mais mais notamment
en france qui est qui et qui s'il est
bien équilibrée permet d'avoir une unité
mais de respecter
l'unicité de chaque individu et ne pas
enfermer les individus dans des groupes
sociaux qui sont souvent des groupes
géographiques c'est le problème
aujourd'hui de l'immigration concentrés
dans des dans des quartiers et qui fait
que les individus ont du mal à devenir
français et se sentent pas français
[Musique]